specifically asked you are do you see
all men as Predators
sorry sorry but hang on if you if you
say you see all managed Predators like I
said if a man was to say he sees all
women as ex he would be called a
misogynist that would be that would be
the the thing that would be leveled at
him so when we say when you say that and
we're talking about misandry versus
misogyny so you you would be a
misandrist then I'm not gonna lie I have
to agree with you and you come across as
a lovely person and I think I think you
do it unintentionally yeah it's a great
you're just brainwashed I don't think
you realize that I don't think it's
bringing all your opinions
I don't think it's brain rushed I just
think it's unintentional I think it's
misdirection
yeah yeah because when I'm listening to
you speak
I'm hearing where you're coming from but
I'm also hearing and how you're
following this wrong route and the
mistakes you're making like what's wrong
okay the mistakes you're making is like
he's saying blanketing which is a good
nice word it's basically what you're
doing in your stereotyping yeah yeah so
and I could take offense for the fact
that you've just come in here I'm not I
don't think you have done it
intentionally I can take offense to the
fact that you come in here and say oh
I'm not rooting on a used because he's a
lot of men how about you're not rude to
none of us because we're this normal
human being who don't need to be spoken
to in a certain way so it shouldn't be
based on
our sex or you know just the fact that
we're men we're bigger than you and all
these kind of things it should be based
on personal experiences you have
experienced it you need to forgive
yourself and also maybe look at dealing
with that situation properly because you
will spoil a lot of opportunities you
will put yourself in a lot of boxes
narrow off
where you can go to and basically pass
it on unintentionally just how you're
speaking now so what if you switched
what you were saying with race
so what if you were what if you were
going to make generalizations about a
group based on race yeah and say oh oh
but I'm polite to this race can I can I
just can I say something about that
please because that's that's a very
point and I want to say that because I'm
seeing here obviously
um with black men and a black woman now
I I want to say to you that if your
opinion on white people was she I get
where you're coming from because I've
seen the destruction that white people
have caused when we see Kanye West with
all lives matter
that's that argument to me that's a
similar argument because you're American
can you agree to a certain extent what
people say about America because of what
they've done so if you wanna I think
America is great actually oh okay I
think it's a great place to live I think
most people are lucky to come okay well
again I think I grew up so my dad
employed people from India and um they
were very very excited to come to
America there's a lot more opportunity
there than a lot of places in the world
and I think a lot of people in the west
are very spoiled but isn't there a lot
more opportunity for them over here
because of the destruction that's being
close um I would argue I would argue no
then in the UK because I just see the
tax rates you guys have here and a lot
of them are able to I want to know what
the point I want to know what a point
you were trying to make is that so okay
so say if I'm on Tick Tock and I'm
scrolling and I see videos of people
slagging off white people so I can feed
English people blah blah blah I can take
that because there's an element of Truth
there okay because of History
so I don't understand why when you can
look at the statistics of everything and
how men are yeah but imagine imagine but
imagine I walked in here what have we
if we didn't use white people what if we
use black people would it be okay but
what do you mean sorry so what if you
flipped it
I'm going to make a generalization about
a group let's say let's say we did black
people would that be okay
um
I know the struggle for women and and
against men okay so I I knew this guy
right this is an anecdotal piece of
evidence I knew this guy that was in
school with me right and he was bullied
in school by some Asian people right
yeah and when he grew up he said I don't
like Asians right however his idea of
not liking Asians right what came from a
minute uh lens that of his own personal
experience and his own personal trauma
so for him to now generalize all Asians
right would be a wrong thing to do now I
don't know your personal trauma and I
don't know what you've been through
right and you may have been through some
traumatic things but to generalize all
men is the exact same thing that that
guy would have been doing with the race
I think I think where I went wrong with
that is when you say Predator a hundred
percent it depends on the situation
because I'm not taking that back if I
see if I will pass any of you down in
Alleyway there's going to be a part of
me that's going to be scared okay I'll
admit that and because I see you is that
because we're men yeah that's what I'm
saying is that because I'm black no it's
because you're a man
can I say something that I think we're
probably not touching or we'll probably
touch it
um
I guess it's not um you keep referring
back to obviously your personal
experience but talking on others as well
right to back up your story would you
then obviously you said media a lot so I
kind of feel
I don't know shoot me for saying this I
think there's an agenda
to push this to to push work
the hatred towards men yeah that's
called violence against women there's
millions of dollars in funding towards
violence against women it's very
profitable too I've never heard of it
yeah it's it's yeah violence against
women is in organizations like women's
organizations that they get millions and
millions of dollars in funding so it's
very profitable for them to spend the
narrative that men are these horrible
people yep so yeah do you think them
because I think that there's two there's
two things that I've seen coming up
right like a lot of you said that you
know women weren't are kind of oppressed
but I don't kind of see that I think
there's a lot of opportunity now there's
so much funding going into like sports
other areas as well there's equal
opportunities women are getting big jobs
in you know to be fair I personally
think a lot of them are they deserve
they deserve the jobs what I will say
though which is quite confusing on the
other hand is I feel like there's this
agenda you say violence against women
but I almost feel like it's to kind of
disrupt homes
um just interested in with that violence
against women thing right I said back to
I said I'll read some statistics again
um back to you from the national Center
of domestic violence right and it says
the types of abuse that men experience
when it comes to women they said they
said 95 of it is emotional abuse 68 is
physical 41 is psychological 23 is
financial 13 is coercive control and
three percent is sexual
[Music]
I had this discussion with my friend the
reason I say this um should be bigger Do
You Believe I'm Gonna I'm just put this
out there for everybody men can be raped
great great oh great
I'm so sorry do you believe men can be
great
um yeah
yeah yeah of course that happens all the
time someone someone doesn't have to
just be by a woman by the way yeah
and and I must admit this is another
thing you know women and feminists never
talk about is how like there's a whole
prison population and Industry where
rape is like normalized it's great great
grape is um but in prison they're being
grapes by men
does that make it okay no but let's look
in the number so why is gender why is
gender a crucial part of that sentence
surely you hear a human being is
experiencing trauma in that way and you
want to stop it but your immediate
responses oh it's men doing it no no
because the way you see it no no it's
because it's because the way you worded
it you said oh I'm uh like women would
be surprised to know that women yeah I'd
be surprised no but there's nothing a
woman can do about a man being raped in
prison by a raped in prison by an uh
do you know as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible